losing john lennon especially for you
you know i
i guess until i read your book i didn't
even realize how close you guys were
and he asked you to play on whatever
gets you through the night right he
wanted to do a session with you yeah yes
yeah and you play on that and you said
to him i'll play on that
but if this thing goes to number one
which i believe it will
i want you to come and do a live concert
with me yeah but that was the bribe i
mean i sang i did
sang on it and i played on it and then i
said listen if this gets to number one
he said no no it's not gonna get to
number one and
of course ultimately it did and so he he
agreed to come on stage thanksgiving
1974
and play with us at madison square
garden and it was probably
the greatest night of my professional
career because
i remember how the audience reacted
because he hadn't been on stage in new
york since shea stadium
he hadn't done a show up to that point
except the peace concert
in toronto yoko and he was physically
sick before he came on because he was so
nervous
um yoko came to the show before and gave
him a gardenia which he wore
and you know it just was like the stars
were aligned and he came on stage
and it was wonderful we played uh i saw
her standing there lucy in the sky with
diamonds and whatever gets useless
tonight
and we all cried when he came on he came
on to the greatest
reception the loudest roar i've ever
heard in madison square garden i've been
there a lot mr john lennon
it was phenomenal and i think it really
touched him because
it told him how much new yorkers loved
him and you know you get that on the
street hi john how you going but when
you get in front of an audience of 20
000 people
making that noise and the affirmation
that we love you john you're a new
yorker wow
it was pretty amazing he was a friend
for two years that we knew each other
and hang out with each other
until he you know got back together with
yoko and had sean and
i didn't mind that uh it was wonderful
and then of course the tragedy happened
and i never really
never really told him how much i loved
him you don't do
people go and you think i wish i could
have said something before you went but
you never know in those circumstances
the way he died you can't do that